Hello everyone and welcome to C ME 296
diffusion and large vision models.
My name is Afshin
and I'm going to be teaching this class
with Shervin who's in the back.
So before we start, I'm just going to
introduce ourselves.
So Shervin and I are twin brothers and
we have very similar backgrounds.
So we both went to a school in France
called Centrale Paris.
And then we came here to the US to do
grad school. So on my end, I went to MIT
and then Shervin went to the ICME
department at Stanford.
And then after that, we've had pretty
similar backgrounds in the industry.
So we both went to Uber first and then
we went to Google and now we're both at
Netflix.
And the reason why we're so excited to
be teaching this class
is because back
in the day
10 years ago when we started in the
field
we actually had our first projects be a
computer vision project.
And it's been crazy the amount of
progress that we've seen in the field.
So this is the kind of images that we
were able to generate. So it's back in
2014.
So it was mostly low resolution, black
and white pictures. So for instance here
there are some digits or
human faces.
And as you all know
nowadays we're able to generate high
resolution colored images. So for
instance those ones that I generated
with ChatGPT.
And the goal of this class is to
understand how this image generation
models work and what makes them work so
well.
So in particular,
this class has two main goals.
So the first goal is to understand the
paradigms behind how we can generate
these images.
And the second one is to understand how
the underlying models are trained and
evaluated.
So in case you're here in this room and
still wondering if this class is is good
for you,
I would say that this class is good if
you have in general an interest in
understanding how image generation
models work.
And in particular, if this is something
that you want to do as a career goal, if
you want to go in the field of research
to do
I don't know like be a research
scientist to
research how to generate images in a
better way, or if you are yourself
interested to do that on your personal
time as a personal project,
or just if you're here out of pure
curiosity.
But that being said,
I want to give a warning.
So this class actually has a pretty
strong set of prerequisites
and I'm not going to hide it.
So this slide is just there to enumerate
the kinds of prerequisites that I think
are good to have just so that you're not
surprised.
So first of all, in case you have some
background in linear algebra,
for instance, if you know what a vector
is, what a matrix is, how you do
operations,
what is a gradient,
what is a divergence
of a vector field,
that would be great.
If you don't everything, that's okay,
too.
So, in this class, we will not assume
that you know everything.
But, if you have at least some
foundation, it's quite important to have
it.
So, linear algebra is one.
Second one that's quite important is
probability theory.
So, in particular, by base rule,
um
conditional marginal probabilities,
uh what is an expectation, what is the
covariance matrix,
uh and what is the Gaussian
distribution.
Again,
if you don't know everything, it's fine,
but at least most of it or at least if
you've heard of it.
Then, you have uh differential
equations. So, here we'll see how we can
use ODEs and STs. So, ordinary
differential equations and stochastic
differential equations, and how they
matter and how we solve them.
And then, last but not least, there's
some basics of ML.
So, if you know uh how uh you train a
model just in general using a neural
network,
uh how you do training,
uh how you do inference, that would be
great.
But again,
we will try to review these concepts
in
a non-exhaustive way, in an intuitive
way, but uh yeah, just knowing those, I
think, would be great.
So, that's uh one warning.
The second thing that I will say is that
this field is very technical in general.
So, if you read
uh
computer vision image generation paper,
you will see that there are like
formulas all over the place.
So, the goal of this class will not be
to go into all these details.
So, we will try to strike a balance
between
not shying away from the math, just
understanding what are the important
formulas,
but also at the same time just
understand why they are there.
So, we'll try to make a big emphasis on
intuition.
All good so far?
Okay, great. So, just moving on to some
logistics. So, we'll have this class
every Friday from 3:30 to 5:20 in this
class.
And uh just again logistics. So, this is
two-unit class.
You can take it either as as a letter or
credit non-credit.
So, as you can see with the setup, uh
the lectures are recorded. We try to
post the videos by Saturday evening.
So, [clears throat] for you watching
remotely, uh if you don't come to class,
it's all good.
We'll be uh just publishing the videos
within the day of it happening.
And then in terms of the exams,
this class has no homework.
But,
we have two exams.
One is the midterm,
and the other one is the final.
And here it's uh the kind of exam that
you may or may not like, but it is a pen
and paper kind of exam,
meaning
the lectures that we will the that we
will do will be about concepts that will
be uh covered in the exam.
And um the important thing is to not
know all the details, again,
just uh
the general formulas and mainly the
intuition as to why they are there.
So, in case it's a little bit vague for
you, we have a similar
class that we do for LLMs. I'm not sure
if you've heard semi 295.
Uh so the format of the exams is very
similar.
So in case you're interested, we put uh
just a link to one kind of exam that you
can expect.
Of course, it will not be the same
questions because it's also uh different
topics, but it will give you a good
idea.
Any questions on the exams?
Super clear?
Yeah, I know it's the first lecture and
I'm talking about exams already. Uh so
yeah, don't worry. It's uh 4 weeks away
and we have time.
Um and yeah, it's a fun class, I
promise.
Cool. Um
in terms of the material,
we have a class website uh and on that
website we'll be publishing the slides
and uh recordings as well. So
just so that you have a way to get the
slides in advance for annotation
purposes,
one thing we will do is to publish the
slides
the day before the lecture, so Thursday
evening.
So you can get the slides and make some
annotations.
And if you saw, there is a tab also top
right cheat sheets.
We also published uh a condensed
four-page cheat sheet on the content of
this class.
So
it's uh gathers all the main formulas
and concepts. Uh so our goal is
if you look at it today, if you don't
understand parts of it, our goal is by
the end of this class
to have everything be very clear.
So if we achieve that goal, I think
that's great.
Cool. Uh Uh, okay, so last thing, so for
any announcements, we'll be posting them
on Canvas.
Uh, and then we have
a forum for class discussions on Ed.
And of course, feel free to reach out to
us. So, there is the addresses here on
the on the slides
uh, if you need anything.
Cool. I think these are all the
logistics.
Is there any questions so far on just
how the class works?
Yep.
Yeah, so the question, so I'm going to
also repeat the question for uh, people
at home. So, how long is the midterm and
the exam? It's 1 hour and 30 minutes.
Cool. I think we're all good then.
Great. So, let's get started. So, I just
want to call out that
in the slides of this class,
what we will do is to explain the
concepts
in the main parts, but we will always
put a reference
to the paper that talks more in depth
about what we're talking about,
just because we only have, I believe,
eight lectures of 2 hours, so we have
nowhere near covering everything in
detail. So, yeah, feel free to look at
them.
They will not be required to know for
the exam. It's just for your own
reference.
Okay, an important note.
So, I mentioned that the papers in the
field are crazy in terms of technicality
and like math formulas.
The same goes for conventions.
So, you will see that from paper to
paper,
uh, things are noted differently, and it
can be very confusing.
So, for instance, you will see there is
a time T that sometimes is between 0 and
1, sometimes it's between 0 and T,
sometimes it's in reverse.
Sometimes epsilon is noted Z or X0 or
X1,
etc.
So,
in this class, what we will try to do is
three things.
First is we will always try to rely on
the most commonly used notations,
so that when you go and refer to those
papers, you're not lost.
The second one is we will try to stay
consistent as much as possible.
So, if you take if we take a notation,
we'll try to keep it
so that you're not uh confused.
And if we don't keep it,
we'll just make sure to call it call it
out.
Okay.
Great.
So, as I mentioned, this class is is all
about understanding how image generation
models work.
So, here you have a typical setup where
you have, let's say, a prompt
where you specify what you want to
generate. So, here I want to generate a
teddy bear reading a book, and I put
that in some model,
and then the model generates
an image.
So, this is what we want to cover.
But,
as easy as it seems,
it's actually
quite complex. There's a lot of things
moving pieces everywhere,
and I'm going to call out the main
moving pieces that we'll cover.
So, the first one is
if you suppose that you have some model,
how do you go about generating images?
Like, what is the process of generating
images?
So, in the text world, is quite easy.
The most common paradigm is you generate
one token at a time because that's also
what people talk and how people write.
So, it's quite intuitive.
But, in the image world, it's not
straightforward.
So, we will focus lectures one two and
three
on this part.
And we will cover the main ways of doing
it, which are the most commonly used
today, which are
diffusion
score matching
and flow matching.
Then
we will look at how we can condition our
model
to generate these images to start with.
So, we'll cover that in lecture four.
So, in some sense, we want to guide the
model
to generate something.
And this is what we will cover. We'll
also cover how to represent images
in a space that's  makes sense.
So, lecture five is going to be about
the model architecture.
So
we'll take a look at the backbones that
are most commonly used today. So, back
in the day, you may have heard of units
as being something that was used.
But, there's currently a convergence of
architectures more towards
transformer-based
architectures such as
the diffusion transformer and variants
such as the multimodal diffusion
transformer. And we will take a look at
those there.
Then lecture six will be around knowing
how to train those models.
So, in particular, how do you
have your model understand
how to generate images
and any post-training approaches that
you may also need.
There's also something that is quite
important, especially in the industry,
which is you have your model,
but you want to run it quicker
because you have some constraints in
your setup. So, we will see also
distillation techniques.
So, this will be in lecture six.
And finally, lecture seven will be about
evaluating
images.
Because if you look at an image,
it's not I'm not sure about you, but
it's not super obvious how you would
define an an image as being, you know,
great or or not great.
So, you will see that the field is full
of acronyms when it comes to metrics.
And each of those
is there actually for a reason, and
we'll try to see that.
And then the second thing that we will
see is this emergence of
multimodal
LLMs that also understand images that
can also help us to evaluate them.
So, this will be for lecture seven.
And today,
as mentioned, we'll start with the
generation paradigm one, and in
particular, we will look at diffusion.
So, who has heard of diffusion?
Yeah, okay, so everyone.
Um so, we will see beyond the general
intuition of roughly how that works,
we'll see exactly how this was defined,
and what is making this objective be
tractable in practice.
So, one thing that I want to call out is
in the first three lectures,
we will assume that
there is nothing as an as inputs.
So, we have some distribution of data
that we use as training sets.
And what we want is to generate images
that are like them.
So, in mathematical terms, we want to
have a model that is able to sample an
observation from the data distribution.
So, in in a sense, we'll only focus on
unconditioned
generations for the first three
lectures, including this one.
Cool. So, speaking of data distribution.
So, let's suppose we have a set of
images. So, here uh
uh long running example would be teddy
bears. So, here let's say we have a
collection of teddy bears as training
images.
Our goal
is to
understand a way
to sample an observation from that data
distribution that is new.
So, what we want to do is
to be able to generate
an image that is in that data
distribution. So, here for instance uh
giraffe.
And
again,
just emphasizing that this is
unconditioned. We're not putting
anything as input.
We just want to generate a sample that
is following that distribution.
So, how do we do this?
So, you will see that
most, if not all methods out there, they
all have something in common.
They all start their image generation
process
from noise.
So, they start from noise, and then they
refine the image to be the final image.
So, I want to just spend some time on
why that is the case.
So, we'll define what noise means, by
the way, because you will see the term
noise and then you will see this like
grayish image.
So,
you will see that this noise is actually
something that you can sample from an
easy distribution,
the Gaussian distribution, spoiler
alert. So, the the first reason why it
is something that we want to do is
because it is easy to sample from noise.
It is easy to have some noise.
The second thing is
noise has some randomness that allows
you to generate different images.
So, even if, let's say, you have a
condition,
if you start from noise
that is different, let's say, from
another generation,
you will be able to end up with a
different
end image just because the starting
point is different.
So, the second reason, it introduces
some randomness.
And then the third one is,
as I mentioned,
noise
is basically equal to
a Gaussian distribution,
and that distribution just happens to
have very nice properties.
So, it simplifies a lot of the math, and
we will see a little bit how that is the
case in the diffusion case.
Cool. So, intuitively, does that make
sense that noise is
good starting point?
Yeah?
Okay.
Cool. And just to complete that
intuition,
in the 3D world, how sculptures go about
sculpting their sculptures,
they start with some,
you know, some rock,
and you can you can think of this rock
as having shapes
that are a little bit noisy. It's not
something that you are defining. It's
something that that's just there,
and that will be different from a rock
to another.
So, one analogy that I like to think of
is this image generation process is a
little bit like if you were a sculpture
and you wanted to, you know, sculpture
from from rock.
So, yeah, I will leave leave you with
that quote from Michelangelo that I
think also
uh reflects that pretty well.
Cool.
Yep.
Mhm.
So, when you say uniforms, you mean the
same thing. Like, let's say a blank
Yep. So, the question is, why do you
want to start from noise but not from
something that is predefined, let's say
a black or sorry, a white canvas, let's
say.
Uh so, yeah, great question. So, you
will see that what makes
the end So, the the generation process
sometimes involves some randomness
in the generation process. Sometimes it
does not.
The randomness
is something that occurs at the starting
points. So, if you were to always start
your process from the same starting
points
given that everything else
does not introduce some amount of
randomness
you will always end up at the same
end points.
So, in a sense, what you want is
to have some variation introduced
somewhere
in order to not always end up at the
same place. So, I'll give an example,
this uh you know, teddy bear reading a
book.
If you use a generation paradigm that
does not have any stochasticity in its
process,
then if you always start from the same
point,
then you will always end up at the same
end point, and that's probably not
something that you want just for
diversity purposes.
So, that's that's the intuition.
Yeah, good question.
Cool.
Um okay. So, what we will see, what
we'll focus on for this lecture is
a landmark paper that I will talk
a lot in depth.
It's called DDPM.
That was the first that
applying the dis- this diffusion
paradigm
for images in a successful way.
So, what we're going to do is to go
through what makes this approach work so
well,
and the underlying mechanisms that lead
to the loss function that we have.
So, in particular,
the idea that we have here is
what we want is to generate new images.
So, what we do have is a set of training
images,
and our goal is
if we were to start from noise,
how would we be able to recover those
images?
That's what we want to learn.
Cuz as I mentioned,
during our generation process, our
strategy is to start from noise and end
up with a clean image. So, here what we
want to do is to use
those training set images
to learn
that denoising process.
So, in that regards,
we have two processes that have a very
particular name. So, the first one is
called the forward process
that amounts to taking
an image
from your training sets
and
you
are actually corrupting that image.
You're adding some noise.
So, here you have some process that you
define
that goes from some image x t minus one
and then produces an image x t
by adding some noise.
So, again, this is a process that you
define. So, you know what Q is in the
forward process.
And what you want to do
is to start
from that noise distribution that is so
easy to sample
and then go through the reverse process
to actually denoise
that sample
back to the
clean space.
And so, what you want to learn
is
a model that is something we'll
characterize with the parameters theta.
What you want to learn is
how you would go from
a noisy image to a less noisy one.
So,
you may
you may wonder, "Okay, so you're talking
about x t's,
but we don't know what is x t, you know,
it's just a noisy image.
How do you go about just representing
images in the first place?"
So,
here we will just see one way of
representing images that is not the way
people usually go about it. That's
something that we'll go more in depth in
lecture four, but I just want to tell
you how you would
try to represent images in this
framework.
So, as you know,
an image is composed of pixels.
So, you have a height
and you have a width.
So, each pixel is actually composed of
three values,
red, green, and blue.
And this allows you to cover a number of
colors.
So, based on that,
you can represent your image
as a function of all the pixels that are
composing that image,
where each of these pixels
contains some value for each of these
colors. So, you can think of each pixel
as having three values, one that
represents the amount of red, the other
one that represents the amount of green,
and the other one that represents the
amount of blue.
So, based on that,
it is fair to say that you can represent
images in a vectorial fashion.
So, here the dimensionality of the image
in this example
would be equal to number of pixels times
the number of dimensions you need to
represent in a pixel, which is three.
So, here you would have uh n dimensions,
where n is equal to number of pixels
times three.
So, this would be one way to represent
your images.
Of course, this is not the most clever
way of representing images, and we will
see that more in lecture four.
But, what I want you to remember is
when we talk about images here, when we
say X0, XT, and so on,
what we're talking about is actually
vectors.
And these vectors are the ones that are
representing these images.
Makes sense?
Cool. Uh so, speaking of vectors, so I
told you there is a prerequisite on
probability theory, so I'm just going to
cover the basics here.
Um so, you may know
the common distribution that's called
the Gaussian distribution, normal
distribution, where you have some random
variable that is drawn from a
distribution of mean mu and then
variance sigma squared.
Well,
you can have the same thing for vectors.
So, I know all these papers, they assume
you know that.
When you read it, it's not super clear,
so I just want to emphasize.
You can also have
random variables that are vectors, and
in this case, you will have
a vector that is drawn from a
distribution of some mean, and the mean
is a vector,
and then some variance,
which is actually represented by a
covariance matrix.
So, don't worry if you don't know about
the covariance matrix, because most of
the time,
we actually simplify the covariance
matrix to be
a variance times the identity.
And we call this formulation actually
uh so, these are like isotropic
Gaussians,
because what that means is that the
variation of the data across all
directions is the same.
So, most of the time, to just simplify
the math,
what we will assume is that the
covariance is actually equal to sigma
square I,
which is the diagonal
matrix which you see here,
and not the super complicated covariance
matrix.
So, by the way, do you remember what
covariance is? Roughly?
Okay, so maybe I can just recap. So,
what is covariance? So, covariance is
a quantity that quantifies
how two random variables vary in a
linear way.
Of course, there is some mathematical
expression, but this is like the general
intuition.
So, speaking of intuition,
when we say that
a distribution is isotropic,
this is what we mean. We mean that the
variance is the same across all
directions. So, you can think of it as
some circle
where the color represents the the
density.
Yeah?
Okay, cool.
Uh and of course, what's great about
Gaussians is you also have an analytical
expression that's quite simple about uh
probability density function.
So, I'm just putting this ear here, and
it's easy to compute.
That's great.
So, going back to what we call noise,
so here
we saw that images can be represented by
vectors.
So, when we say we sample from noise,
we will say here that we actually sample
from a standard normal distribution.
So, we usually note that epsilon. So,
epsilon will be drawn from a normal
distribution of mean zero. So, zero is
actually the the vector, the zero
vector.
And then the covariance will actually be
the identity matrix.
Yeah.
It's a great question.
It's a great question. So, the question
is is the representation continuous or
discrete? So, we talked about pixel
values that were discrete 0 1 2 until
2055, but in practice, these are
actually scaled
between, let's say, minus one or and one
or like some value that's more of a
float. So, you can assume that these are
actually continuous.
Right, but you you can assume it's
actually continuous. Yeah.
Yeah.
Right. Right.
So, there's always some assumption and
so, uh here at least the when you say
there is no
there is no correlation between pixels,
so here we actually mean the noise.
So, noise we actually just sample at
random, so yeah. Yeah. It's not true for
actual images, though. No, it's not
true. Yeah. Yeah.
Great questions.
Cool. I'm just looking at the time and I
know we have a lot of content, so I'll
just go a little bit faster. Just want
to know if the pace so far is good.
Yeah? Okay. I don't want to lose you cuz
I think this is the first
uh lecture that is maybe the most
difficult
in terms of like math.
So, it's just kind of sad that this is
the first lecture.
Um but yeah, let's continue.
So, as I mentioned, what we want to do
is to take clean images and to corrupt
them.
So, what we do is we take some image
that maybe we have noise.
And we add some noise.
And we actually add these quantities in
a weighted fashion.
And
these weights
are actually defined by us.
So, if you remember
when we talked about Q
the process that we define for the
forward process
is actually something that we define.
So, this is how we noise images. So, we
take an image, we take some noise from a
distribution, from the normal
distribution, and then we
do a weighted average with some weights
that we will see.
And speaking of those, you will hear of
a term recurring term across all papers,
noise schedule.
So, the noise schedule is actually
referring to the coefficients here
that you use
to multiply these these values.
So, it's a schedule because at some
point you may add maybe less noise than
some other points.
Yeah?
Okay, great. So, let's
let's go a little bit more into the
math.
So, we start from
X0.
And then the way we go about adding
noise is
we have our
forward process that we've defined Q
which is actually something we will draw
from a normal distribution.
So, we can express
the quantity, so Q of XT, so the noisier
image compared to the less noisy image
as a normal distribution centered
on that less noisy image
with some coefficients
where you add some noise
which is something that is represented
by the covariance matrix beta TI.
Yeah?
So, what that means I'm just going to
rewrite this in a very
So, it's it's it's just what that means.
So, it's
XT
is equal to 1 minus beta
XT minus 1
plus
square root of beta
and some noise.
Right? So, this uh
seemingly
math formula is just nothing else than
just you taking your less noisy image
waiting that by some coefficient and
then adding some noise with some
coefficient.
Now, you may wonder why are you using
these coefficients?
So, we will see later in the class why
we do that.
But, you can see that the variance
of this whole thing is preserved
from one step to another. So, you will
see that this
way of
noising images is called variance
preserving.
VP.
We'll see that more later.
Okay, cool.
So, speaking of the noise schedule
So, these beta T are not typically
uniform. They're varying.
And the way they're defined in the DDPM
paper is
they're gradually increased
as in you will start from your clean
image
and you will just add a a bit of noise.
And then maybe a little bit more.
And again and again and then at the end
you will have much bigger noise.
And the reason why people do that is
because when you're close to the clean
image
what what you care about is to learn
those little details.
But what you're when you're closer to
the noise
what you care more about learning is the
general shape of the image.
So this noise schedule is actually quite
important in our ability to learn.
And it's just one way of doing things.
Yeah?
And as you as you can tell it's between
zero and one.
Well, because otherwise you would have a
negative value in the square root.
Cool. Moving on. So
if you define your process like this
then it turns out
you don't need to noise your images in a
sequential way in order to get the T the
T number T1.
You can actually go directly from your
clean image
to the step number T.
Do you see how you would do you you
would do that?
It maybe it's not super obvious, but
I told you that Gaussians had very nice
properties.
So here epsilon the noise is drawn from
a Gaussian distribution.
So if you were to rewrite so
first of all I will just define
alpha T
which is just equal to 1 minus beta T.
It's just a reparameterization.
So here it will be 1 minus alpha T.
So here what we're saying
is
XT minus 1
we can also use the same formula
which will be equal to square root of
alpha t minus one
x t minus two
plus square root of one minus alpha t
minus one
and the other Gaussian.
So these noise are independent.
So if you were to express
x t
as a function of x t minus two
and the epsilons
what would you do?
So here I'm just going to expand x t.
So here I'm just, you know, in
parenthesis.
So it's equal to alpha t uh square root
of alpha t
um so I'm directly going to multiply
this quantity by the one that we have
here.
So it's
square root of alpha t
times square root of alpha t minus one
x t minus two
plus
square root of alpha t
square root of one minus
alpha t minus one
t minus one plus
So by the way, I'm just doing some math,
very basic math. Um
plus
square root of one minus
alpha t
epsilon t.
So far so good?
Okay.
So here
we have our first term, no problem.
Then what we have
is a weighted sum
of random variables drawn from a
Gaussian distribution.
So,
I told you that these Gaussian
distributions had very nice properties.
So, it turns out
that if you have
two random variables that are
independent and drawn from a Gaussian
distribution, so you can really have
this as being equal
to the standard deviation of this
quantity
times
a random variable that is also drawn
from a Gaussian distribution.
So, how do you add these variance? So,
you have the variance of everything that
is equal to the variance of one plus the
variance of other.
So, here in terms of what that how that
looks like,
so
here you will have the variance that
will be equal to
alpha t, so it's basically this squared
plus this squared.
So, it's alpha t one minus
alpha uh one minus alpha t minus one
plus
one minus alpha t, which is equal
to so, this one goes away
and then you have one minus
alpha t
alpha t minus one.
So,
what does that mean?
That means that
x t
is equal to
square roots of alpha t
alpha t minus one.
So, I'm just like
copying what is above.
x t minus two
plus
the standard deviation of this one,
which is square root of the variance.
Times a random variable that is
drawn from the normal distribution.
And this sketch of a proof
is just a way for us
to prove that you can actually cascade
these things
up to zero.
And therefore, you can have an
expression
of
the noisy image at step T
as a function of the clean image at step
zero.
And this can be expressed as a function
of alpha bar
where alpha bar
is equal
to the product of the alpha eyes.
So, here
alpha T alpha T minus one is just the
the start, right? But, if you continue,
it's just the product of all the alpha
alpha T's.
Does that make sense?
So, what I just, you know, wrote on the
on the board is just a way for you to be
convinced that what I'm saying is uh
is making sense. So, you can express XT
as a function of X0
by just
using alpha T bar
instead of this beta T.
Cool.
Uh so, yeah. So, the derivation, you use
the fact that the variance of uh the sum
of independent Gaussians is just the sum
of the respective variances.
Um and by the way,
there's many
derivations we can do in this class. The
problem is we do not have time.
So, here is the first one, which is why
I I wrote on on the blackboard, but if
we do not have time,
we will always have
a little
message at the bottom of the slide that
just tells you what the trick is.
And you can safely assume that if we
don't derive
this thing in class, it will not be
asked during the exams.
Okay?
Cool.
Uh moving on.
So, now what we have done
is
just defined our forward process, and we
just
also derived the convenient way to noise
our image
from step zero to step T without going
through all the all the steps.
So, what we will do now
is
to see how we can actually
go about determining
the process that denoises that forward
process.
So, what we want to know is how that can
we go about
seeing
what P theta of X to T minus one given
XT is.
So,
as I mentioned, what we want to do is to
learn P of theta.
So, in case you have some experience in
ML,
you will see that the common trick that
people do
is given some training data,
what they want to do is to maximize the
probability of your model seeing the
training data
maximized. They want to maximize such a
probability
with respect to theta.
So, they want to find the parameters
theta
that maximize
the probability of your model
of seeing your training data.
So in this case, training data is just
our training images. So it's clean
images.
And then
our model here is something that
has P theta in it. So it's the
probability of
an image happening that we will see how
we can condition.
And what we want to do is to find the
parameters theta. That do that.
So you will see that whenever you talk
about probabilities,
you will always or most of the time talk
about log probabilities.
One because the logarithm function has
pretty nice properties. And then the
second reason is
that is just computationally more
stable.
Cuz probabilities are between zero and
one.
So if you have very very small values of
P, then it can be a little bit unstable.
So before we determine that,
I just wanted to go through some
refresher
of a concept in probabilities that is
the joint probability distribution.
So here, if you suppose
that you have two random variables
that are drawn from two distributions.
Let's say it's X1 and X2 the random
variables.
Then
you can compute
the probability the joint probability
distribution by
taking the probability density of X1
and multiplying that by the conditional
probability of X2 given X1.
So this is just by definition. It's the
probability chain of rule.
And
in practice,
when you have a joint probability
distribution,
one way you can represent that is
through a heat map.
So, here you have, let's say, your two
uh two axes. One is uh representing uh
the one along X1 and the other one along
X2.
And then here,
the color that you see here is
the density value
of this joint probability distribution.
So, this is, for instance, you know, one
uh
one um
uh square.
And the way you would go about doing
this for uh the conditional
probabilities, you would actually just
look at one column.
And here, the probability of X2 given X1
would be the proportion
of
the value of the joint probability
distribution in that square
over the sum of all the squares
for that given value X1.
Right? So, so far, I'm just recapping
what we know about joint probability
distributions and conditional
probabilities.
So, what I want to tell you is
a notion of what we call
marginalization,
which is
if you want
to obtain
the probability of just one random
variable,
then what you can do
is to sum the joint probability
of that random variable and a second
random variable,
and you can sum it along
that second uh variable.
And this is called marginalization.
Do you all know Have you all heard what
marginalization is?
Yeah?
Okay, cool. So, what I'm saying is a
little bit obvious then.
So,
in this
figure, so the way you would obtain P of
X1 is you sum all the squares
relative to X1.
Again and again and again and you can
reconstitute
your probability distribution.
So, that's the way you would see this
from a graphical perspective.
And so, we saw that when we only have
two random variables,
but you can very well do that when we
have
T
random variables.
And so, here we have the
probability chain rule
like at the top of the slide. So, you
have P of X1 * P of X2 given X1 etc. * P
of XT given X1 up until XT - 1.
So, this is just uh
extending that to a dimension of T.
And
one notation that you will see very
often in papers is this one.
So, the joint probability distribution
of
T variables
is
usually noted P of X1
T.
So, just to save space.
And the reason why I'm presenting the
slides is just to tell you that this is
the main notation that people use and
this is what it means.
Cool. And with that simplified notation,
you can just rewrite the formulas from
before as follows.
So, now if we were to come back
to the problem that we had around
finding
parameters theta
that maximize
the probability of our model seeing the
training data.
Here, what we want to do
is to express
P theta of X0 or log of P theta of X0.
So, we've seen a few slides ago that
the way we obtain X0
is sampling from
a noise distribution
at time T
and then going step by step from big T
to big T minus 1 etc. up up until zero.
So, in order to compute this quantity
one idea for you could be to take the
joint probability distribution over all
the time steps
and then sum across all these different
quantities except X0.
AKA you can just marginalize.
Right?
So, one idea
is to say
that the logarithm of P theta of X0
is the logarithm of
the integral of P theta of X0 and then
X1
up to T
D of X1
to T.
So, this is just a definition of
marginalizing.
So, the problem with this formulation
is that it's actually something we
cannot compute.
Because here we're We're
let's
marginalize, let's sum across all
possible trajectories from noise to
clean image.
So, the problem is there are like many
of them.
And then these x's
we saw that these are vectors
and they can be pretty big.
So, long story short is
this is in practice something that we
cannot compute.
Which is the reason why we have a recipe
that we'll go through in the next 33
minutes
as to how we can compute that
using the forward process that we have
defined.
So, in the interest of time
I'm going to skip some blackboard
derivation, which is fine. I'm just
going to give you the trick.
If time permits, we can do a few ones.
But
the important thing for you is to just
understand the high-level strategy
around obtaining the loss
that will be used to train our model.
That's good?
Cool. So, let's start with the first
step.
So, I told you that this expression
is something that is actually not
something we can compute
because it's just intractable.
So, a common trick that people use
is to find
something that is easy to compute that
is not necessarily the quantity of
interest
but maybe a a bound
that is close to what you want.
So, here what you want is to maximize
that expression.
So, if you were to maximize something
that you know is lower than that, so a
lower bounds,
then it would also allow you to gain
some confidence that you're maximizing
the right thing.
So, there is a very scary formula on the
slides, which we'll go through right
now,
which is the elbow.
Have you heard of
>> [snorts]
>> the elbow
before this class, yeah?
Elbow stands for evidence lower bounds.
And what that means is it's an
expression of a quantity
that is a lower bound of the quantity
that we care about.
And actually, this is quite important,
so I think I will derive it.
So, while I'm cleaning the blackboards,
I just want to tell you about
what the trick is.
The trick
is
that we have our forward process
that we have defined,
so Q.
And what we want to do is to
have Q be
in some way something that we
appear like
in our
in our equation, we want to involve Q in
some way, because we know what Q is.
Q is this forward process that we have
defined, you know, when we do the noise
schedule, this beta T, alpha T, we know
that.
So,
what we want to do is to express that as
a function of Q.
So, we go back with uh the log of P
theta of X0,
which we said we tried to marginalize
across
X1 to XT, so I'm just going to rewrite
what we had above.
And then what I'm going to do, as I
mentioned, is
have Q appear.
So, very common trick.
What I'm going to do is
to multiply the numerator and the
denominator by that quantity.
So, I'm going to do
this one
times
Q of So, you given a clean image,
what is the trajectory that is given by
Q? So, it's Q of X1 to XT
given your clean image.
Okay, everyone is following me so far?
Just a
a very regular trick. So, okay, so what
where do we go from there?
So, I'm just going to remove the log for
now. So, this is this is true.
So,
this expression
is actually nothing else than the
expectation of these
quantity.
Because this is as if you were sampling
X1 through T from this
distribution.
So, it's as if you were writing this,
right?
So, it's as if you were saying it's the
expectation
of this ratio, which is P theta of X
zero to T over Q of X one to T given X
zero.
Where
X one
through T is something that you
draw
from Q of X one
through T given X zero.
Okay, I hope
So, don't worry by the way, it's all
going to be in the recording is going to
be much clearer in case you cannot see
very clear what I'm writing, but what
I'm writing is the expectation this
quantity is the expectation of the ratio
between P theta of X zero through T
over Q of X one through T given X zero
by sampling X one through T, so the
trajectory one through T
via the forward process that we know.
Which is given by by X one through T
given X zero.
Okay?
So,
where do we go from here?
So, it turns out that there is a very
common trick
very common trick out there that's
called the Jensen inequality.
Where if you have
a convex or a concave function, you have
some very nice property about something
we're going to see.
And in particular in this case
log
is a concave function.
So, if you have the log
of some expectation
it's actually something that is
greater or
equal than
the log
Sorry, the expectation of the log.
The expectation of the log.
Now, I'm not going to write this whole
thing, but you know what I mean.
So, this is Jensen's inequality.
Jensen.
And this is exactly what we get here.
So,
one way we progressed is instead of
summing through all possible
trajectories,
now what we're doing with is we're
actually sampling from trajectories
that we're drawing from
the forward process,
which we know.
And now you're wondering why in the
slide are we sampling X0 through T,
but here I said X1 through T sample from
X1 through Q of X1 through T given X0?
It's because if you take the expectation
of this whole thing,
then you take the expectation over the
X0
of expectation of X1 through T
times that, so you you use the
chain rule of probability that we saw
right before and it's exactly the same
as just one expectation of sampling the
whole joint probability distribution
through this Q
X0 through T.
Does this make sense?
So,
you may see this formula and wonder,
"Okay,
it seems super complicated. Like, how
can I compute that?"
Well, right now you do not know that it
is tractable. I'm just telling you.
But the intuition here is we're actually
not summing through all possible
trajectories.
We're actually summing
through trajectories that we're sampling
from the forward process.
Yeah?
So, now it's step number one.
Step number two
is proving or showing
that this is something that you can
compute.
But before that, I'm going to again
give you some refresher of a very
important concepts
that is the KL divergence.
Who has heard of KL divergence?
Yeah? Everyone? Okay. I'm just going to
remind you what KL divergence is. So, if
you take two probability distributions,
so let's say P
and Q
and you want to measure how far
apart they are
then there is some operator
that is here the KL divergence, which
quantifies how far apart they are.
And the way
the way they do that is
by taking or maybe it's something I
treat on the slide, so I'm just going to
continue there. So, by taking the sum of
the log of the ratio between these two
probabilities
weighted by
the probability distribution P.
So, in the discrete world
it's going to be like this.
But we're going to be mostly in the
continuous world and in the continuous
world the KL divergence is this but in
integral form.
And it's the same as saying you take the
expectation of the logarithm of the
ratio
if you were to assume that X is sampled
through P.
Yeah?
Okay, so given that
we can prove
that the elbow term that we saw
so you know this lower bounds
here
it can actually be expressed
with terms so some terms that we
actually don't really care
and we're just going to ignore.
Plus a term here which is the KL
divergence
of
Q of Xt minus one given Xt and X0.
So that's the first distribution.
And the second distribution is actually
the probability
of having
the less noisy image Xt minus one given
Xt.
Which is the thing that we want to
learn.
So we don't have time to derive this
but
it's actually not that complicated of a
derivation. You would just take
this expectation of log and then you
would do some um
some manipulation here and there and you
can basically pop up the KL divergence
operator through that.
Okay, so I think this one I will need
you to trust me that this is equal to
this.
So why are we happy?
The reason why we're happy
is
because we have a clear
comparison between two probability
distributions, one that we care about
and another one that is potentially
something that is tractable.
And so just to tell you what Q of Xt
minus one given Xt and X0 means. So it
means that if
I were to give you
a noisy image
and a clean image,
my question for you would be
what would be the less noisy image?
If I were to give you these two.
So, the good thing is that at training
time, you know X0.
So, you can compute this quantity.
So,
a natural step for us
is now to show that this quantity that I
mentioned is indeed tractable.
So, we're going to
see what Q of XT minus one given XT and
X0 is.
So, again,
it is the fact of wondering what is the
distribution of the less noisy image
if I were to not only give you the more
noisy image, but also the clean image,
which is actually a lot of
information.
So,
you may remember or you may know, may
have heard of base rule, and it's
something that we use, a trick we will
use here.
So,
using the notations that you would
commonly see and read and hear out
there,
it's the fact of saying that the
posterior
is equal to the likelihood times the
prior
over
the marginal likelihood.
So, in this case, it's P of A given B
equal to P of B given A times P of A
over P of B.
And so, knowing that,
it's actually quite easy to show that
this
this thing is tractable. So, this is
probably something we will derive.
So, here
So, what we want
is
Q of Xt - 1 given Xt and X0.
So, if we were to use Bayes' rule
with
Q of
the conditional probability based on X0.
So, if you have this formula
So, if we were to write this
by considering P equal to Q
conditional on X0.
What we would do is So, what I'm doing
is just applying Bayes' rule.
So, it's equal to
Q of Xt given
Xt - 1
X0
time times
Q of Xt - 1
X0
over
Q of
Xt given X0.
You all agree?
I'm just doing Bayes' rule.
So,
it's something that I have not told you
so far
but Q has a very special property.
Q is
Markovian.
So, what does that mean?
It means that
Q of Xt
given everything before
let's say before
is actually equal to Q of XT
given XT minus one.
In other words, you only need to know
about the previous
step
to know the current step. So it's called
a Marco Markov process.
So this simplifies to Q of XT given XT
minus one.
And then we saw before that Q of XT
minus one given X0
and Q of XT given X0
are quantities that are tractable.
There is normal distribution. Do you
remember like this derivation I I made
with like okay, let's replace XT minus
one as a function of XT minus two
until getting X0. Do you remember?
So these these two quantities they're
tractable. This is tractable. This is
tractable.
Actually this one we don't really care.
Because
we want to compute Q of XT minus one
given XT and X0.
So here we're only varying XT minus one.
But Q of XT given X0 everything is
fixed.
So you can interpret that as a constant.
Yeah?
And so what we end up with oh, cannot do
that.
Yeah.
Are you referring to this one?
The left hand side.
So
here's the thing.
In this derivation
the quantity that we actually care about
is Q of XT minus one just given XT and
X0.
So, this is just because of the
derivation
of the elbow the fact that we be
end up here.
Yeah, and that's just the fact that we
just are interested in what is the
distribution of the least noisy data if
we know what the noisier one is and the
clean image is.
That's the thing that we care about.
And so here
what I want to say is
that this
is something
so X of T minus one
knowing XT and X0
is proportional
of
Q of
XT
given XT minus one
times
Q of XT minus one
given X0.
This is Gaussian,
this is Gaussian.
The product of probabilities of Gaussian
is a Gaussian.
I'm not going to derive everything, but
please trust me that
the form of Q of XT minus one given XT
and X0 is a normal distribution in
particular with the mean of
this formula. I'm not going to read it,
but it's a function of
the noisy image
and then
the sampled noise that allows you to go
from X0 to XT.
Okay?
So,
this distribution is exact.
Meaning we have not approximated
anything.
And this is something that we know
because we have defined our forward
process.
And here we're cheating a little bit
because we're saying what is the less
noisy distribution if I give you the
more noisy one but also the clean image.
So it's a little bit of cheating because
at training time we know what X0 is.
Of course at inference time we do not.
So
Okay, so we we we know one term.
The second term is the this P theta of
XT minus one given XT.
Now let's show that it is tractable.
Well, that one is going to be easy
because we can choose what P theta is.
And
turns out that it's very fair for us to
assume that it is also a Gaussian
just because the
forward process of XT minus one given XT
is also approximately a Gaussian.
So just if I justification for that is a
little bit more into the weeds so I'm
not going to go into that but
all of that to say that in this part
we're just making the assumption
that
what we want to learn is a Gaussian.
Okay?
So what we end up with
is a KL divergence
of a Gaussian
with a Gaussian.
And I'm not sure if you remember but
early in the lecture
I told you that we know the probability
density function of a Gaussian. We know.
We have the explicit formula. We we do
we do know.
So
if you replace these
into the KL divergence formula which is
this integral of log of P over Q and
then P.
Then
turns out
you have a lot of things that simplify.
And at the end of the day
what you end up with
is just
the distance between
the noise that you want to predict
and the noise
that you sample to go from the clean
image to the noise image.
Take the L2 distance of that.
Is everyone clear with that transition?
So, what we did
was
we had that elbow which was equal to the
scale divergence term.
And what we said was, "Okay.
Looks good because P theta is what we
want to compute.
And then this Q Q thing is something we
have defined. So, let's try to see if
it's tractable."
And what we said was, "Okay.
Let's see if Q is tractable. Q of XT - 1
given XT and X0." So, we went to into
the math.
We did the base rule.
And then there is this
latter derivation around actually
determining the mean and the variance of
that normal distribution that I've not
covered just because it's like just too
much. And it's okay to just assume that
if you do this at home, you you end up
with
a normal distribution of this mean.
And then we also showed
that P theta
is something that is tractable.
And the way we have shown that is just
by assuming that it is a Gaussian.
So, Gaussian of some mean and then some
variance.
And at the end of the day
we end up with a loss
that is nothing else than an L2
regression
on the noise
that we have added to our clean image to
obtain the noisy image.
Do you agree that that loss is pretty
looking pretty good?
Yeah? It's very tractable. You just have
to regress your noise on the
on the noise from the clean image to the
noisy image as a training training loss.
It's great.
So,
okay.
I want Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Thank you. So, the question is
what is epsilon theta? So, I'm going to
go through each term.
So, here
what is shown on the slides is
loss of DDPM. So, DDPM is this whole
framework of defining a forward process
in order to determine how you want to
reverse reverse the process, which is
why it's called L-DDPM.
And what is on the right-hand side of
the equal sign
is
an expectation
over
T that you sample, which is the noise
level if you want.
X0, which is
clean images in your training set.
And then epsilon is
random noise that you sample from a
normal distribution. That's right. Uh
standard normal distribution, which is
basically a Gaussian of um mean zero and
uh variance the identity matrix.
So, what is in the expectation is on the
one side
epsilon theta, which is
your model predicting
what noise was added.
And then on the right side is epsilon,
which is the actual noise that you added
from
the clean image directly to the noisy
image.
And what is in the parentheses? So, uh
square root of alpha t bar x0 plus
uh square root of 1 minus alpha t bar
epsilon, this
is
equal to xt.
So, it's the noisy image.
Cuz you can go from
the clean image and
epsilon directly to the noisy image
with using the identity that we have
seen.
So, in other words, it is saying, "If I
give you
the noisy image,
please compute the noise that was added
and compare that to the actual noise
that was added."
So, one thing that I will call out is
there actually two arguments.
You not only give the model
the noisy image,
but you're also giving it the
information of how noisy it is.
T.
So, here T is between 0 and big T. So,
if T is more towards 0, it means you
didn't add a lot of noise.
And T, if T is more towards big T, it
means you you've added much more noise.
So, it just allows the model to know,
"Okay, given this noisy image, how noisy
it is?" So, it can calibrate how much
noise to predict to remove.
Does that make a bit more sense?
Perfect. So, yeah, but great question
and
we're actually going to go through
exactly what that means in practice if
we want to train the model.
But before we do that, any other
questions on
on the loss.
Yeah.
So, the question is this loss represents
the elbow. So,
we are actually going to see exactly how
we went from the first step to to this
step in the next slide. So, I'm going to
answer your question right now.
So, apart from this, any other questions
on this?
We're good?
Okay. So, I'm going to answer your
question now. So,
do you remember the strategy strategy
plan we had with these four steps?
So, we went from
this maximum likelihood estimation
problem that we wanted to perform.
And we said
we have a lower bound. So, that's where
the elbow comes.
Then
from the elbow, which is a lower bound
of what we care about,
what we said was actually expand the
terms.
And we were like, "Oh, wow. We actually
have a KL divergence between two things
that seem tractable."
And then what we said was, "Okay, so
let's look at that KL divergence term.
There are two two parts to it. One is
Q of XT minus one given XT and X0. The
other one is
P theta of XT minus one given XT.
We saw that
these two terms were tractable. They
were Gaussians.
And we knew what the mean of these two
Gaussians were.
And then what we said was,
"We have two Gaussians. We know their
probability density functions. We have a
KL KL divergence of that.
Then we can actually compute this whole
thing analytically.
And as a result of that,
end up with a loss that's very simple."
Now,
there is something that I simplified
that I've not told you yet, but I'm
going to tell you now.
When you simplify
this KL divergence, what you what you
actually get is the expectation of this
L2 regression
times some coefficients.
You can think of it as a the weight of
the loss.
And this is something that
you as the person who's training the
model can can choose.
Now, the authors of DDPM,
they they tried different ways. They
tried the actual thing. They tried
without by having a coefficient of one.
And they actually said, "Okay, it's
actually not that bad. You can actually
take equal to one."
But this is something that you can
actually choose.
And this is how you end up
to this last expression.
So, let's see how we do training and
inference.
So, we see the strategy. So, training
So, what you want to do is to minimize
the loss.
So, what you do is you sample the amount
So, first the clean image from your
training set.
You sample your noise.
And then the time step.
And in that way, you constitute the
noise image. So, you can go from clean
image with the amount of noise up to the
noisy image.
What you do is you take that noisy
image.
You take the noise level.
And then what you do is you try to
predict the noise that was added
using your
model.
Which right now we don't know. It's just
a black box.
And you compute the loss and you do your
back propagation.
So, that's the training.
And then the inference is
you sample your noise, which is super
easy to do.
And what you do is you go step-by-step
from noise to less noise to less noise
to less noise up until arriving at T
equals zero, which is
clean image.
And here what you do is you use the
expression of P theta of XT minus one
given XT,
which is something we have derived,
which is a function of the noisy image
and
the predicted noise that you can remove.
And then you add some noise on top of it
because let's remember that
P theta of XT minus one given XT is a
normal distribution.
So, the noise here just
corresponds to the standard deviation of
that distribution.
And when you do that from big T to zero,
you then obtain your clean image.
Cool. I know this was a lot. I know this
is lecture one. I can tell you that this
lecture is probably the most difficult
of the eight first lectures. So, if you
feel a little bit
like it's a lot to digest, it's normal.
Hopefully, we've tried to make it a bit
more digestible. Luckily, there's a
recording. We have the the notes. We
have everything.
I mean, hopefully, if we don't, just let
us know. And with that, I'm going to
give it to Shervin.
>> Thank you, Evgeny.
So, now we saw how to generate a clean
image starting from noise.
And what we're seeing in this equation
is that we need to repeat the same
procedure big T times.
And
the thing is
this big T is usually
quite large. So, it's the order of
magnitude of a thousand, for example, in
the original paper.
And let's say you take
the reference point of existing image
generation models before that, let's say
VAEs or GANs, and you compute
the amount of time it takes to generate
a single image, which is a forward pass.
So, you have to do that now T times. So,
let's say you had to do it for 100
milliseconds, now it might take the
order of magnitude of minutes,
which is not great.
So, one comment that we have out of all
of this is that we want to bring the
computational burden down at inference
time.
So, what can we do to make that happen?
So, I will first show
the equation that Afshin has shown
linking the generation process from step
T,
which is a
denoiser image, to step T minus one,
which is the slightly cleaner image,
which was defined by that generation
process written on the slide.
And we're going to try to see how to
make these steps shorter.
So, what can we do? Okay. One strategy
could be to try to skip steps.
And um like the first thought that comes
to mind is to write down equations and
see if we can link
a lower step to a higher one
and see if we can make a connection
between the two without going through
each of the middle steps.
So, let's start by writing down the same
equation for step T minus one,
and then T minus two, and so on.
And you come
you come up with a relationship linking
a lower step that's you index by some
other sequence of numbers that you call
tau I, which is a sequence of numbers
between zero and big T where the gap
between consecutive numbers is bigger
than one potentially.
And you end up with a relationship that
involves
step number tau I, which is the larger
step number,
and some sum over
over some numbers and and some
sample noise.
And as you can see, it hasn't
brought us very far because you still
have
quite a bit of model evaluations to
make, which is exactly the gap between
the two steps.
So, okay, that that didn't work. What
can we do next?
So, let's just keep that sequence of
numbers that's represents
sequences of steps that that's keep some
in between.
One thing we could do is try to guess a
formula that links two different steps.
And I'm showing you one proposal of such
a formula and
I'm not going to derive it,
but
just going to verify that this makes
sense for two consecutive steps. So, if
you say tau I is step T
and tau I minus one is step T minus one,
when you replace the numbers in there,
you will find again
the relationship between step T minus
one and T.
And
so, let's suppose you use such a
relationship to link
two different steps,
then
what you realize in practice
is that
as the amount of stochasticity that you
have within steps increases
then your quality is going to get worse.
As a function of of the step size.
So, did that make sense? So, by the way,
the
density of formulas in this last part is
slightly higher
than in the previous parts, and the goal
here is more to get the intuition of
skipping steps and seeing how it works
more than looking like at each formula
separately.
So,
yeah, so
Does that make sense so far?
Okay, great. So, now we have tried to
skip steps, and we have found a
relationship that could link the two,
but we see that the quality is not great
when you take large step sizes.
So,
what you're trying to do now is trying
to do these large steps skipping
but avoid that level of stochasticity
between steps.
So,
in order to do so, we go back
to the drawing board and look at the
derivation of the loss function that you
had in the case of DDPM.
And one thing we realize
is that the key
your key part to get to the formulation
of the DDPM loss
was the marginal Q of XT given X0.
And we realize that when we do modeling
choices that reproduces that
relationship on Q
then you can
approximate
that then you can have a model that is
based on the same loss.
So, this is one
observation.
So, the problem statements comes back to
finding such a Q
that reproduces these marginal
probabilities.
So,
like with the same X Q of XT given X0.
And
the second constraint that we want to
put ourselves
is to have a generation process that
foregoes of that stochasticity term
in order to try to see if we can
mitigate the
uh the fact that quality generation the
quality of generation gets worse.
Cuz this is the problem statement.
I'm going to write this down in more
mathematical terms.
So, we want to find
a family of function, let's say Q sigma.
And I'll I'm going to say what sigma is
very soon and motivate why we are
talking about the family function here.
Such that we match the marginals with
respect to the DDPM forward process.
And the second condition where I said
that we don't want any stochasticity
between two generation steps
is translated by the fact that we want P
theta
of the least noisy image given the noisy
image to be deterministic, meaning that
once you have
XT
then your generation process gives you
XT minus one as a one-to-one mapping.
So, there is no more noise term.
Does everyone agree
on that?
So, we're going to So, I'm going to
throw at you a formula and verify that
that this works.
So, this
formula
is parameterized by a parameter that is
called sigma here.
That is a hyperparameter.
And
by reasoning with with the process of
induction, we can verify that the
marginals
Q sigma of XT given X0 matches the ones
that we had in the case of DDPM.
And
when you set sigma to zero,
you can see that this term becomes
just a mean with zero variance.
So, you can link XT minus 1 to XT with
with no stochasticity.
Okay, great. And so this state of mind
and coming to the realization that you
have such a family of functions that
verify that and the fact that this is
attractive to seek
is part of this DDIM paper where the
only term that changes with respect to
the title of DDPM is this P
probabilistic to I implicit.
So, the probabilistic part of DDPM
translated the fact that when you
generated a new a clean image out of
noise, you had this probabilistic nature
between two steps.
But in this DDIM formulation where you
don't have stochasticity at the
generation step between two consecutive
steps,
the stochastic part only comes when you
sample your initial noise, so your X big
T.
And this is why we call the diffusion
process implicit because the
probabilistic part
is not something that you see between
consecutive steps, but rather set at the
beginning of the generation process. So,
I think there was a question at the very
beginning on why don't you start at the
same point every time? So, if you were
to do that, then DDIM wouldn't have
worked
because once you set your initial point
of noise, then you determine
deterministically your end image.
And then in this case,
one thing we can do is at each step T,
we can approximate
our belief of what the clean image could
look like. So, if you remember
the marginal distribution Q of XT given
X0 gives you a relationship between XT,
X0, and the noise.
And if you rearrange the terms, then you
can approximate X0 at every step.
This is just
the rearrangement of of terms that that
proves that.
And then you can plug in
uh that approximation of X0
into the formula that we had just before
to determine XT minus one by waiting
this term accordingly
and adding to it
adequate noise
weighted by the right coefficient at
step T minus one.
And as you can notice here,
there is no added stochasticity by
construction
of this family of forward processes Q
sigma when sigma equals zero,
which is the property that we were after
here.
So, does that make sense so far?
Yep.
So, the question is where's the skipping
steps here? We have not skipped uh
skipped uh skipped any steps so far.
We're just constructing
uh the generation process.
Okay, great. So,
if you recall,
you had this
DDPM generation process that you had
that did not skip steps.
So, you had to go
one step at a time, and now you can
you can adapt the formula that we saw
from step T to step T minus 1. But now
between these
schedule of steps, tau eyes,
where at at step tau I minus 1,
you
predict your best guess at what the
clean image X0 is based on your step tau
I,
and you approximate the noise that you
need to remove, and you weigh each of
these terms at the step
tau I minus 1,
which is how you get
uh this formula.
And then here we define some concepts,
so
uh when I talked about the sequence of
steps, tau eyes,
so the length of that sequence
is
S, so we call it S.
And a T over S is the the effective
speed up, so instead of spending T steps
to generate a new sample, you spend S
steps.
And with that in mind,
the value for the speed up that people
typically take is between
10 to 100.
And as you can guess, it's not
it doesn't come for free, so it's a
trade-off between speeds and actual
quality that you get in the end. And the
actual values that people take are more
on the order of magnitudes of 10 to 50.
And here I'm showing
what the authors showed in one of their
experiments, the evolution of the of one
metric. So here FID means Fréchet
Inception Distance, which is a metric
that we'll cover in lecture seven when
we'll talk about evaluations.
Uh so now I'm not going to cover it in
detail, just going to tell you that it
translates
uh how the generated images look like.
And
so the absolute values don't necessarily
mean much, but uh we can see the impact
on quality based on
relative differences.
And you can see that you can speed up
the process by taking S of size such
that that 20x you're not too far
from uh the baseline of not skipping
steps at all.
Yeah, so the
So the the discussion here is So we
realized that when you skip steps
the stochasticity that that you had
between two consecutive steps at the
generation process turned out to
generate worse a worse estimate of what
a lower step would be, which is why
removing it is better here.
Uh so here we don't show the comparison
with methods that do not remove the
stochasticity, but the paper goes at
length into showing that when you when
you do have stochasticity, the results
are much worse.
So if I had to summarize the thought
process that we went through,
we
looked at the DDPM loss.
We looked at the core ingredients of
what got us there, which was Q of XT
given X0.
We chose Q sigma that verified the same
relationship. And we made Q sigma such
that it could be made uh so we could
have a generation process P theta that
is deterministic.
And once we had this deterministic
generation process, so we call it DDIM,
and then we skip steps and we get
the transition from
from a generation process that needs to
go through T steps to one that only
needs to go through S steps,
which is
like which is which is what we got in
the end.
And with that,
thank you very much for your attention
and have a great weekend.